well in our morning rounds a new warning
about sugary drinks a Harvard led study
in the journal Circulation found people
who drink two or more sugar sweetened
beverages a day had a 31% higher risk of
early death from cardiovascular disease
each additional soda sports drink or
sugary beverage increased risk increase
the risk by 10% our dr. Tara new rule is
a cardiologist at northwell health and
joins us with more on this study Tara
great to see you so we know sugary
drinks are not good for us what does
this study tell us in further detail
well previous research research has
shown that sugar sweetened beverages are
associated with things like diabetes
weight gain heart disease and stroke but
what we didn't really look into was the
increased risk of mortality or death
there have been very few studies that
looked at that and this research really
did show that the more sugars sugar
sweetened beverages you drank the higher
your risk of death primarily from
cardiovascular death but also from
cancer death as well and so researchers
looked at essentially two studies one of
about 80,000 women one of about 30,000
men who were followed for about 20 to 30
years they gave them questionnaires to
ask how much they ate and drank what
their health and lifestyle factors were
like and they found that in those who
drank about one to two sugar sweetened
beverages a day the risk of death went
up about 14 percent over two drinks per
day the risk went up 21% now again
important to point out this is not the
kind of study where we can say cause and
effect it is an association that they
saw but definitely again adding to this
body of evidence that sugar sweetened
beverages not so great for our how about
a diet soda
that's a great question a lot of people
want to know the answer to that and the
American Heart Association actually last
year came out with a scientific advisory
saying that look that can be part of a
healthy diet especially for those
individuals who want to cut back if
they're drinking a lot of sugar
sweetened beverages this study did look
at artificially sweetened beverages and
found that there was no real increase in
mortality unless you drank more than
four of these drinks a day and you were
a woman and so they need more research
to look into that female effect it may
have been that women who were overweight
or obese were trying to switch to
artificial sweetened beverages and they
were already at high risk so why was it
higher in women do you think it's
because of weight is that what you're
saying so this research in general in
terms of the sugar sweetened beverages
did show an effect that was higher in
women and the researchers were quick to
point out that we don't
know why it could be that the biology of
women is different how we metabolize
these drinks are different our
physiology or it could be the
methodology of the study that women
tended to report their drinking use
differently from men the American
Beverage Association did not respond to
our request for comment but their
websites is that soft drinks are safe as
part of a balanced diet do you agree
with you know the lead researcher even
of this study said look if you're
drinking one or two soft drinks a week
probably the incremental increase in
risk is very small but what we know is
that sugary sweetened beverages are the
leading cause of added sugar in the
American diet it says even cocktails at
night right that have sugary these
sports and energy drinks the fact of the
matter is Americans are should be
consuming for men about nine teaspoons
of added sugar a day women six teaspoons
on average we consume 20 teaspoons of
sugar a day when you look at a 12 ounce
soda for example that has about 10
teaspoons so with one soda
you've already over gone over what you
should have you know consumed for that
day what are we left with boring water
pouring water boring okay healthy water
fresh water okay yes miles are we
throwing labels read the labels taking
away all my happy place thank you so
much thank you